so Cristiano we're here at Boyle's
comic-con are you enjoying it today
Justin my first time in Wales
I've only seen the inside of a hotel I'm
the new University but the people here
are super nice as usual
I've never had any problem with
convention crowds that people are still
interested in the show and your
character and super respectful I love
convention this is actually a really
good one
I'm glad you enjoying it everyone's
enjoying you being here as well I tell
her oh no on season 3 of Game of Thrones
it's getting going sky high in the races
even higher than it was before
what are you enjoying about this season
compares the previous ones and how has
it compared filming wise for you well
it's just sort of interesting to me hi
obviously you said the really difficult
hire and so I think seeing how it's
climbed in popularity in the UK and
other countries outside the US has been
really interesting to me because
obviously it's absolutely mastered
tonight
Danny's story that Episode four was
fantastic I think a lot of people have
thought it was the best episode yet she
really kicked ass great stick with with
you and bran and Asha and and you and
your merry gang now you also have Thomas
brodie-sangster in any country don't you
what is it like filming with those guys
welcoming into new people to the show
into your gang well obviously we work
with Natalia and it's art and and
obviously exactly maybe we've worked
together since this is day one but it's
been nice to have a new dynamic and
obviously Thomas is an immensely
experienced after he's done it the Love
Actually is legend and also Ally we all
got on really well not to say I'm not
let go
it's a nice little tight that grip
already even after one season so I'm
looking forward to what what what the
future will bring I don't wanna say very
cryptic at the moment with with Thomas's
character isn't it you know yeah it's
definitely Eggman
but it really brings a sort of mystical
magical aspect into our group and it's a
bit of magic already it's been going on
a while has been getting stronger with
bran I think you know with that whole
kind of walk spirit he's going through
how are you finding that storyline what
do you think why do you think it will be
taken
well that for me was something I was
looking forward to big time
it's gonna open up a whole new path
acting-wise you know it depends in
season for her they are they want to
portray it but maybe even the Saints
we've gotten involved in working there's
a lot of fun it's a whole new different
emotion for Hodor is not the calm gentle
soul is something completely different
you enjoying playing that have you been
enjoying playing that yeah I know it's
for me it's no I'm not schizophrenic
yeah I think it's a great character
obviously the seal joke of having learnt
your lines and stuff but assume more so
much more to turn on as a challenge you
know
I hide the pervasive so many convey so
many emotions so little dialog so I love
it and filming wise location wise where
have you been when this season so far
well it's all been within a 30-mile
radius in my house no nowhere glamorous
as yet he knows for that season we we
definitely gonna be saying more Hodor do
you think in season four yes Buddha is
still around I know technically we're
not really on the book very much for
next season but I think I left arts will
still be very much else I don't think
they'll drop the character lurch so I'm
looking forward to getting started it'll
be nice to see you what do you go they
said she Liverpool character you say I
mean how do you think you'd further in
Hodos works in such a lovely guy but in
a such a horrible world and I as a new
there's been a couple of times
definitely but if it was me I would've
grabbed Theon by the throat when he was
taking over Winterfell but yeah I sort
of felt it shoot it on something then
but yeah I don't think I don't think I
would fare very well and Westeros to be
honest I think I'm I'm too much of a
soft touch I need to be more ruthless
what do you think it takes you like
strive in the Game of Thrones world you
say you need to be ruthless four star
yeah
loyalty is bad need to be selfish need
to have a huge agenda
probably sleep with a family member all
sorts of horrible crimes you need to
commit to be a citizen of Westeros
morning yeah yeah very much do you think
you said how you'd fur in a hotel's
world but how do you think if we
transported Hodor into the modern day
2013 what do you think he'd be doing
probably be a interviewer what would he
do it might be Prime Minister there's
been worse I don't know a politician
they probably talks about stances they
do last time we spoke to you one day you
know maybe I hope you on the Iron Throne
oh yeah that's that's a given I think of
it I think it'd be a great leader
Westeros yeah yeah if it survives who
knows if you did have to get the chop
and go with Rhodes obviously we hope you
don't say but how would you like to meet
your maker I would like to be in like a
active periphery and may be protected
bran suffers here during moments where a
sort of steps out of his is making mild
and he sort of steps up and does it JT
and I have a feeling something more will
happen feelings that's just my feeling
like don't put me on this meters or the
watchers have a feeling that something
else will happen we see have any of her
dogs kind of conspiracy theories out
there with like what is it could Glee
and there's so many although I'm he
talked to me about that last time but do
you think we might ever see them you
know the the sand or and the mountain
and Hodor facing or any point so I'm
wrestle you Rama hanging but I'm pretty
sure yeah yeah I think I think you
should definitely be very different if
it isn't overtime we're not going to be
alive arm wrestle but maybe like you
know if you're not gonna do it now just
petition George Martin for us yeah I
don't think in George I don't think arm
wrestling would be not thirsty enough to
George the favorite SAS you've seen on
us on the show so far it has to be the
one with the rap in the pocket
thankfully some George's twisties tangi
stomach over when you see it and
thinking about it though they're not
gonna do that but you do have to be any
other character pal from hose or who
would it be
Varys yeah listen yeah I don't think it
could be any better job than caucus
polygamy isn't both it's a fantastic
fantastic character that whole sorceress
storyline that we've seen come up with
him you know though kind of bringing
yeah it's definitely a complicated and
interesting chap yeah it's more
complication and more interest behind
the character of her doors to come out
yeah bathrooms there yeah I definitely
think there is because no one really
knows who he is way as the way is ways
so tall enough Stefan to everybody else
around them so yeah so I'll be
interesting if that comes out I hope it
does is there been any kind of skills
that you had to pick up while you've
been working on Game of Thrones I know
it was your first kind of big job wasn't
it going on there so others carrying I'm
planning I can play a lot and you know
Brandon's getting bigger isn't it having
seventeen that's one shirking shirking
work
no yeah bronze like 29-foot told her
yeah at least y9 fit but we have the
cart yeah it's a bit of low say with
your back
yes and though you know it's weird
actually the cart is more difficult to
push yeah but you know I'm a donkey you
had a bit of an oh my god moment for
your audition didn't only not your
audition but your scene where bran is
sunless is by the lake in the godswood
with OSHA ask a little bit of her oh my
god babe it wasn't it how did you
prepare yourself
I felt no that wasn't oh my god moment
for me as well there's a certain unique
feeling waiting in a bush knowing that
there's 160 people cameras and you have
the sort of wander right buck naked
amongst mes it's not something I ever
plan to do but I was paid yeah on my
wish list of things to do as an adult
yeah I want to be a naked giant but the
huge prosthetic penis strapped to me is
line is priceless
yeah that's always the same people quote
I don't think people can forget that
readily it's burning in their memories
do you psych yourself out when you're
gonna do something like that and did
they tell you when your audition that
was on the cards yeah and they said
there's a nude scene so if you we need
you to be prepared to do that so I
thought yeah well this is Game of
Thrones so I'm not gonna turn it down so
yeah what do you know on a serious note
I thought you know Westeros is for the
people of all shapes and sizes and you
don't have to be big bodied and bronze I
think it's important you know not
everybody is like just in the world
you know ever to be up TV you don't have
to be a certain type cos to be an actor
so is it great to show you for that
isn't it so many different types of
people and characters in there yep well
hopefully I will open up the door for
for a more variety of people at
Hollywood talking about Hollywood I know
that although it's not in Hollywood he's
40 foot in Santa's George RR Martin's
actually brought a little cinema did you
know information here yeah I can ask he
was do you think or would you like to
therefore see maybe Game of Thrones the
movie I don't know how that would work
to be honest you know it's I don't think
it's of the movie but maybe it depends
on the final typically written there's
all sorts of rumors and stuff
imagine it smells terrible hey nose
don't quote me we love it and it's great
it's so expansive isn't that's what's
great about the world
yeah there's no way be fat that in the
two hours I wanted to ask you also what
and what being part of Game of Thrones
has meant to you well it's changed my
life to be honest
the only positive ways it's opened up
doors which I never thought I would be
able to open you know I mean it's give
me any confidence it's ever made new
friends there are all sorts of work
opportunities met so many fantastic
people it's just been simply the dream
come true let's continue and it just
continues it gets better and better to
be honest so I'm very grateful for
you